we got this story from bounding into
Comics oh I like this one Disney Insider
speculates Bob chapek was fired because
he crossed Disney's HR department that
pushed radical woke politics
Disney Insider wdw Pro recently
speculated on why he believes the Walt
Disney Company acts chapic just months
after renewing his contract through
2025. at the end of June quote the Walt
Disney Company board of directors
unanimously voted to extend chapik's
contract as CEO for three years chairman
of the board Susan Arnold explained
Disney was dealt a tough Hand by the
pandemic yet with Bob at the helm our
businesses from Parks to streaming not
only weathered the storm but emerged in
a position of strength they ought to
mention that he's the right leader at
the right time however Sunday he was
giving us Walking Papers they issued a
press release discussing the move to
Fire chapic and bring back Iger Disney
Insider appeared on Midnight's Edge and
speculated as to the cause of chapex
firing when we see a change like this
this tends to come from the
institutional level this doesn't come
from anything that's very small so what
I think probably happened is Bob chapek
he's got some enemies and those enemies
were primarily coming out of latondra
Newton's Department over in HR with the
Dei stuff and that's highly connected
with ESG
he continued and I'm going to bet that
as he was looking for places to make
Cuts in the company he may have crossed
a threshold he wasn't supposed to cross
and in doing so those big three
investors were talking about the
vanguards the black rocks that they may
have said to the board were ready to
begin reassessing our relationship with
you we're not talking about fans who got
mad about Star Wars we're not talking
about individual investors who said I'm
going to pull my ten thousand dollars
out of Disney we're talking about people
who have the ability to say I'm pulling
my billions and billions and billions
that are generated through 401ks and
other things that we have associated
with you unless you get rid of this guy
now
speculation but uh I don't know I kind
of think it makes sense but I'm not
convinced that chapic was like anti-work
or anything but I think ESG is a
powerful Factor so um I saw people
misinterpreting this from both sides
like first I saw Christopher rufo saying
that chapex firing was a rebuke of woke
leadership so we're supposed to buy the
narrative that chapek was anti-woke but
also that he was woke and then I saw
other people complaining uh about uh Bob
chapek being anti-lgbt and betraying his
LGBT employees
so I I don't know what narrative to buy
here I think really it's just that he
was a pandemic CEO and now they're
getting rid of him for training a
replacement
I was going to say anytime one of these
like companies whether it's Disney or
Nike has some sort of incident
conservatives like to pounce on and be
like get woke go broke but exactly even
under this guy's leadership like year to
year Revenue was up his first year I
think six percent then from 21 to 22 is
like 20 so he was doing a good job
financially speaking and so it makes you
wonder how woke the company wants things
to go if this is the guy who even when
you know Buzz Lightyear's got like a gay
kiss and these things are happening even
he's like allowing that to happen what
was he preventing from happening where
now HR or something it feels like he
stepped on his toes and now they want
him out and they're going to bring back
uh Bob and they just put their new their
newest movie Strange World I think it's
called they have the first openly gay
protagonist for a kids movie
and I saw people celebrating this jpeg
didn't do anything to stop that yeah I I
it's kind of weird because I I assume
they're all woke you know what I mean
yeah weren't they both pretty woke and
weren't they both kind of instituting
these policies yes stay broken I mean
Iger was always more openly political
and openly woke than chapek but uh I
think that they might have been planning
to Fire chapek and at the end of the day
I think it's it's important to
understand the importance of the ESG
score the institutional money the
BlackRock money that is there that is
calling for a lot of these policies to
be implemented no matter what uh the
price is going to be paid for them so I
don't think these are even company made
decisions I think these are decisions
made even higher up than that as we're
seeing the same kind of cultural push
all at once pushing these larger kind of
ideas out there now there there's
reports that Disney had a 1.5 billion
dollar streaming lost last quarter that
their theme parks aren't doing too well
with customers being unhappy they they
also have ESPN which people call a
syncing Network so a lot of things are
happening here but but again Disney
doesn't have the best record especially
with their child actors especially with
them previously thanking concentration
camp guards in East turkistan so
um this is a company that that again is
is Major it's a big powerhouse it's
interesting to see the switch and I
think people are going to attribute it
to their own political beliefs rather
than actually what's really happening
there you could blame a CEO as you want
but I think it's important to highlight
the bigger pressures above the CEO that
that they need to comply with you notice
that uh
you know they're talking about policies
of Dei and uh man it's really
interesting isn't it because you know
what how do you pronounce it day is that
you pronounce it in Latin I've never
said it day in Latin I've always tried
everyone referred to as d-i-e for no no
it's a Latin word yes but it's diversity
Equity inclusion what do you mean
there's a Latin word
day well I think it's pronounced of God
yeah of God right right and uh it's very
weird that they use the same word for
their non-theistic religion it is a
religion that was on purpose do you
think that's on purpose I don't know if
it's on purpose but it's a heck of a
coincidence I think that we we are still
closer to a cult symbolism that we might
be comfortable with acknowledging and
it's interesting because the same way
that like under a Catholic monarchy no
decision would be made at any
institutional level without first
thinking well how is this going to be
viewed in the eyes of God we do the same
thing in this country except how are
black people or how are gay people going
to feel about this so we are literally
as Tim said worshiping like this well
hold on idea I I agree and I disagree I
think uh it's not even about race
because Candace Owens they don't they
don't care what she and Kanye have to
say or Kyrie Irving like all of a sudden
their race is erased from the
conversation it really is just we have a
cult we have things we claim and if you
agree with it that's what they're so
they're really talking about
the religion like it makes it more more
about the religion
how does this impact our religion is
basically how they view it I think
that's true but I think if Candace Owens
were saying things that they agreed with
uh then she would be you know a face on
MSNBC or something like that I think
it's because they view her as basically
a race Trader that she is now disinvited
from the conversation because she's an
Uncle Tom or whatever but but it's it's
it I guess this is my point
Candace Owens can have similar opinions
to Ben Shapiro and Ben Shapiro's Jewish
and she's black and it doesn't matter
but then you can have someone who's at
MSNBC woman who got fired recently I
can't remember but uh it's like it's
like the race doesn't matter it's it's
if do you agree with them or don't you
agree with them if you're a white person
you agree with them you're in if you're
a black person and you disagree with
them you're out
yeah I think that the Candace would be
considered like an outlier with what
they regard to be like black interest or
things like that I mean she is a
dissenting Voice Within America and with
also uh the black community so I think
that you know even on Twitter every time
she goes viral all of the replies are
from black people calling her a race
Trader calling her Uncle Tom things like
that
um and so even regardless of skin color
I mean she's still serving I think what
they ultimately want which is like
enforced equality in this country and I
think uh and I agree I think the reason
why they take such offense to Candace
specifically is because it does damage
their narrative seeing people who are
just like hey I don't agree with your
ideas and my race isn't a component then
they're like no that can't be allowed
like we can't have people who say those
things so you're internalizing white
supremacy I think there's more room for
Dissent though if you're not white
because I don't think Kanye would have
gotten away with what he said to the
extreme that he has
if he were white I agree that you know
like and Dave Chappelle too for that
monologue he done on SNL right if if you
are a marginalized person you are
allowed to wield the sword more so than
if you're a white person so you can be a
somewhat dissenting voice if you agree
with the cult and challenge it in a way
like actually you're being a bigot then
they'll be Oh They'll defer right so
obviously there's like a weird
identitarian hierarchy to what these
people believe and anyway the reason I
brought this up not to just you know to
go back to what I was saying is they
call it God whether intentionally or not
Dei means god of God that's that's
creepy to me yeah apparently pronounced
there you go see I knew I wasn't getting
it right because I don't speak Latin or
anything like that but it's both right
yeah both right well
Elon Musk tweeted uh vox populi Vox day
or whatever and uh I know what that
means I mean simply put because I played
um uh BioShock Infinite you played that
right uh I owned a copy of okay so you
know the Vox Fox popular I think the
voice of the people and then so and I
know what day means or day whatever and
so I saw what he said I understood the
gist voice of the people is the voice of
God or the uh is the however you want to
explain it and then I was like Ah that's
very funny touche Elon Musk and then I
looked it up and when I tried searching
for it
Latin doesn't come up
wokeness comes up when you search for
day when you search like yeah what what
comes up is not God or Latin what comes
up is all of these websites about equity
and wokeness and all other creepy stuff
it's a church Equity is particularly
scary because it's harder to Define that
than equality I mean if it's equality
okay everyone should be equal Equity
implies this like vague Narrative of who
has had Injustice done to them and they
Define The Narrative so that is of
course going to be anybody who isn't a
straight white male and so because of
that they have this like trojan horse
that's painted in the blood of like
black slaves and in that they're going
to contain all of this stuff that's
going to disenfranchise white people
straight people normal people from being
able to access these positions in favor
of what they want which is the Dei stuff
uh which of course is never going to be
you're never going to see like a board
of like a bunch of um you know Latino
people and they're gonna be like you
need more white people it's always
diversity being defined as less white
people more people of color which is the
way that they Define it because then you
have all non-white people versus white
people people of color and it's like
well I mean frankly you know white
people we have all sorts of different
eye colors different hair colors not
white you're not did you see exactly he
didn't even know exactly you don't
recognize my people's struggles I come
from the Slavic people that that been
through a lot of struggles right my
family's been through some crazy stuff
and if we're going to be going through
sorry sorry what's your ethnic
background well so I'm Irish and some
people even say that Irish aren't white
so maybe just Irish uh Irish and French
I think okay so you're white uh Luke is
Polish so that makes him a person of
color but sorry Luke but but the
horrible thing don't interrupt me all
right like marginalized voices speak no
no but but if we were truly going to go
through okay your people were oppressed
okay there's a long history there's a
lot of cultures there's a lot of people
who were oppressed who dealt with
slavery who dealt with uh oppression
whether by the Russians or the fascists
or whatever it may be my family went
through all of that but at the same time
it's kind of disingenuous to tell the
people the more of a victim you are the
better you are the better you are in our
system and I think that right there is
not only promoting victim mentality but
also making you know cheapens things and
and it and it disincentivizes people
from actually taking grips of control of
their life and saying hey I'm in charge
of this I'm not a victim I set my own
destiny here and and that works in
direct parallel against it which is
which is absolutely uh disingenuous and
horrible I think and has a very negative
effect on the psyche of a lot of these
people and individuals let me let me
tell you what else I find very strange
because everybody knows what Equity
means right
Equity means the value of shares issued
by a company and more the uh he quote he
owns 62 of the group's Equity it means
the value of a mortgaged property after
deduction or of charges against it
it references a trade Union uh uh an
equity card or whatever and then on
Google it says the quality of being fair
and impartial
interesting in Latin it comes from
aqueous
uh equitas and equity and then equity
and I think it's pretty interesting that
the colloquial understanding of the word
was never fairness we always use equity
at least in my life to refer to your
value So when you say something like
oh I have a hundred grand equity in my
home or whatever
you're specifically referring to what is
the intrinsic value of of what you have
or something like that
there's something
creepy about them coming out and using
this terminology the value of shares
they shouldn't accompany stakeholder
capitalism and things like that and then
referring to how they need Equity it
sounds like they're trying to Define
what value do you bring to this system
now I
perhaps to stretch but when read when
we're at a point history where you have
the great reset the world economic Forum
coming out outright saying stuff about
overpopulation for years and then
they're asking you about how we can push
for Equity it sounds like to me they're
arguing can we push for a system where
people have a higher value than
liability yeah and a lot of this stuff
is crazy especially seeing the NHL say
that there's too many white people in
their league I said that yeah and that
they're having uh they're having uh
specific Outreach programs that are
going to make it more Equitable uh that
are going to make NHL teams more diverse
so we don't see that in the NBA I mean
if we're going to be doing that with the
NHL are we going to be doing that with
with the the MBA just to be fair here
and obviously that's not going to happen
here but when you have a society based
on artificial things and allegiance to
the cult rather than actual marriage
you're going to have a society that
fails this is why a lot of people
believe communism failed mainly because
it wasn't the best person for the job it
wasn't the hardest working person for
the job it was oh you have the perfect
Allegiance you have the perfect family
lineage you have the person who we're
close with and friends with who's going
to be in these positions of power
because you're close to us because you
you bow down because you respect
authority that's not a society that is
actually Progressive that's a society
that is degressive and overall hurts
Humanity getting people to give their
perfect allegiance to a government
requires taking their religion away from
them that's reeling it back to religion
that's they want to make the state your
religion they want to make obedience to
the cult your religion rather than of
course an actual religion basis or maybe
even God and worshiping yourself that
also too I think is another important
element that's what representation is
all about it's just like I need to see
myself all the time even when I'm not
looking in a mirror I need to see myself
in media yeah and it's a problem if you
see color and if it's a problem if you
don't see color which which again is is
just such a confusing political social
landscape that we're supposed to be
living in that a lot of people are
living in fear a lot of people are
uncomfortable and when it comes to humor
that that you know softens a lot of this
kind of uh uncomfortability that is
banned that is censored that is being
attacked and we see Dave Chappelle being
you know called anti-semitic which is I
think absolutely absurd and crazy when
his comments were hitting at everyone
and making people laugh about something
that people are taking way too seriously
and creating more of a divide in our
society which I think is being done
deliberately by Central controllers
because the more that we could fight
each other the less we're actually
looking at the true oppressors the true
multinational corporations the true big
Bankers the true people in power that
are screwing us over and creating this
larger economic Havoc that we're having
to deal with and really screwing
everyone over I I don't know if it's
that I think it's probably more that
that conflict exists naturally I think
people are very tribalistic and I think
that they do have an incentive to kind
of stoke the Flames of that but uh this
is sort of like I think the record of
history and it is interesting how any
identity like we talked about religion
that you have that would separate you
from the state whether it's a religious
identity a cultural identity national
identity anything like that has been
dissuaded and basically erased you're
not allowed to have that and so when
you're looking for an identity now in
this country you have like the state
approved identities you know you can be
like a for example and think about like
since the beginning of time humans have
made Flags to Define themselves and now
we have the pride flag and then we have
all the other flags like that that is
just so telling to where young people
are going nowadays to where they want to
feel like they can be proud of their
identity be proud of something and so
they have to waive the pride flag which
now as I'm sure we'll get into on the
national stage is even more
representative of American values and
American power than the actual American
flag because when you see the American
flag now flying in embassies in Saudi
Arabia or whatever you don't think of
white picket fences in apple pie you
think of gay people you think of things
like that because that is what America
wants to promote on the world stage I
disagree I think of uh soldiers like if
like if Saudi Arabia specifically I
think of oil U.S soldiers guarding oil
fields and poppy fields in Afghanistan I
think of Yemen and the humanitarian
crisis that's still continuing right
there that's causing millions of people
to die but the reason I brought it up is
because America U.S embassies were
flying the pride flag yes and so like
they're just outright not in Saudi
Arabia obviously thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time